- 金外与小彤
- 金外与小彤的精英教笔记
- 今天我们要教大家如何充两人份的手冲
- 因为我们很多人在我们那个底下留言
- 跟我们说他们想要看多人份手冲
- 那我们这一集会拍两人份
- 那三人份我们可以挑战一下
- 然后拉到下一集
- 其实大家好像对于两人份确实蛮好奇
- 基本上我们在做两人份的话
比較不會是直接用double的方式
我們等一下會給大家的一個比例
是我們測試過這樣的比例
喝起來跟就是一杯的量
然後是最吻合的
因為你要去思考
如果你原本用原本的兩倍的粉
然後兩倍的水
你的充足時間假設也是double
你可能換來的會是一個過度濃
或是過度萃取的咖啡
所以其實像我們之前有聊到的是
我们在萃取一杯咖啡的时候
大概的那个时间范畴
约莫是可能两分啊
两分十秒啊
甚至可能终生培的
生培大概一分五十秒啊
那基本上
你充两人份也不会到超过四分钟
我们大概只会啊
就要在三分到三分半左右
这也是为了防止
就是有所谓的过度萃取的问题产生
那等一下给大家的比例
差不多也是将近一比十五
可是他沒有到準確的1比15
因為我們等一下會是用27克的豆子
然後萃取400ml的水
然後我們會分很多段次柱水
那為什麼要分很多段次柱水
其實這個有一個很大的原因
我會希望每次的斷水跟給水
讓他的咖啡粉一直呈現像呼吸的狀態
所以你會等一下再看的時候
他不會有所謂的掛壁
掛壁就是咖啡粉在旁邊
可是你在給水的時候
會有一部分一直進食不到
就是如果一下子給他太多的水
然後例如說你的粉牆
是他就會例如說可能黏在很上面
可是如果你後面的給水都是給少少的
那你最上面的這個地方可能都會一直淋不到
他是吃不到水
所以我會比較希望我的每一頓的注水
都可以讓咖啡很均勻的可以吃到水
所以才會有分多段吃注水這件事情
所以先簡單的講
第一次的悶蒸
然后我们会用大概两倍的水量
也就是大概会抓在50到60左右
那等一下的水温
我们一样会先从92度开始
我们会先做一次的悶蒸
然后在第二次的话
我们会注到总水量的100
对
然后再来的话是100到150
然后150到200
然后200到250
你们等一下可以特别去看
等那个中心绕园
都会有一点点不太一样
尤其是闷针到100的这之间
对跟后面的每个50会有点不太一样
然后最后的啊
250到300跟300到350
属于只有中间注水
对为什么要只有中间注水
就是希望它的流通率可以更高
打开它的通道
对打开它的通道不要让它有毒水的现象然后最后一道注水要帮我特别留意讓全部的粉都打濕到為什麼要這樣做呢就是要確保就是其他的粉
他們的萃出率盡可能的相同
所以這是等一下
我們在做示範的時候
可以幫我們特別去留意的一個部分
然後也可以幫我們去留意泡沫
就是我們等一下在沖煮咖啡的時候
他會有一層泡沫帶上來
你幫我特別去留意
那個泡沫的形成跟狀態
那等一下我們就開始進行所謂的示範
好
所以等一下我們會用27克的豆子
那我們今天喝的是哪一支
朵旺秋
又是我的朵旺秋
對這是小朋友愛喝的
他點的
那這支朵旺秋的話
他等一下在喝的時候
我們會覺得他有比較多的帶有一點點像
除了其他香氣之外
然後它也會比較多
像橘子啊
甜度接近黃糖
然後帶有綠茶的茶感
然後
我們如果再做兩人份的話
會比較建議用大張的綠子
對
因為有時候假設你是做比較中培中深培的
它有可能在新鮮的豆子的狀態下
譬如說它的冒泡量會比較多
那有可能會有所謂的外溢
對
就是它會往外溢出
所以我會建議用比較大的綠子
然後一樣先把它打濕
然後這邊其實在做用大濾紙的時候啊
我自己會有一個小小的習慣
這個習慣你們自己可以斟酌著用
這個習慣啊就是我會喜歡把它折下來
因為我不喜歡就是我在注水的時候
因為有多了一個高度
手中壺會比較容易抬得太高
所以我會習慣的把它就是這樣子
就是
讓它比較整齊一點點
對
然後其實步驟的話前面都會跟這件教的一樣
都是一樣整齊
那我們都不會去拍打它
對
然後我們只會這樣晃進它
然後中間一樣抽個小圓洞
然後就可以開始做我們主要的沖煮
那第一段的話就是剛剛提到的門蒸
然後用小水流的水煮
差不多是50mol
然後你就會看到它其實因為粉量也比較多
所以它在做的平鬆的感受上
對也會看起來比較的茂密
那如果假設你今天到了30秒
你看到它還是在不斷的冒泡
我這個時候還是會建議你可以稍微的在等待一下
可是如果沒有在冒泡我基本上就可以充足
像現在已經30秒了
空間注水稍微的停留一下
看到泡沫出來
小繞圓就好
我們就繞這樣這麼圓就好
所以你有發現嗎
就是其實我沒有繞到最完美
它就會像是一個像火山一樣
然後它差不多像這個樣子的時候
就可以再一樣注到150
所以它就會一直很像在呼吸的一個感覺
然後泡沫它其實也不會特別的外溢有感覺嗎?好像是在呼吸,就很像火山爆發的那個感覺
所以我們其實在繞圓的狀態差不多就是5-10塊錢的大繩
到200
然後等下到250的時候一樣是小繞圈
所以你其實不太需要擔心就是旁邊吃不到水
其實旁邊是吃得到水的,因為它水會擴散
好,等下250到300的話我們就同意以中間注水為主要
所以你會發現其實我的噴牆的高度
基本上它都會控制在一個階段
它就是不會再有太多的水往上冒出來去蓋過它的噴牆
對
然後它也不會有很近似不到的狀況下
然後這邊是300到350
然後等一下的最後一段的話
我們就會從中間開始把全部的粉打掉
對,就全部都繞到
然後確保近似
到400
其實多一點也沒有關係,不用擔心
就像這樣子
然後整個泡沫看起來是比較碰到金黃色
然後它整體的萃取時間大約會落在3分鐘左右
然後我們就等它快流完
然後剩下一些泡沫的時候我們就可以抽掉
這樣就可以抽掉
我們大概是2分50秒結束
好,我好像這個樣子
就可以來喝囉
這什麼意思?
沖完了
來,你先請
我先請
先聞一下
這隻就很香啊
它的花香很奔放
其實應該想說我們在教的手法
基本上就是你們來這邊喝到的咖啡的手法會是一模一樣的
所以如果你们可能在充足的时候觉得有疑问
或者是例如说来到这边有疑问也都可以问我们
因为我们不会在教你们的状态下是我们其实自己也不会使用的
基本上我们都是自己在使用
所以我们会分享我们这样的做法
对
那也是好方便让大家
有时候可能看到我们的频道啊
在实测
然后可能例如说可以跟我们分享
然后他喝到的状态
然后跟可以观察我们平常在充足的时候的状态
它那个藤花的汤气很浅
不会因为两人份它变得太重
然后再来是我觉得它的延伸性很强
然后这边帮大家简单的小科普一下
就是
好我问小朋友
如果今天假设我用15克的豆子
冲1比15
跟我用27克的豆子冲1比15
那
谁的风味会比较多
27克
好为什么27克
因为它的那个每颗豆子里面的内含物不一样
所以它27克因为它量多的关系
所以它里面的东西会换出来更多好像很懂耶还是有认真上課對對對其實基本上你要去了解到的就是有時候啊
你在做這樣兩人份的時候
你會蠻意外的
它可能會產生出來的風味上會飽滿
然後風味上會更多元
例如說可能假設你充單人份的
你會覺得說可能它有橙花香
它可能有橘子比較帶茶感的
可是如果你在做兩人份的時候
它會比較容易轉成果汁感
然后会比较饱满一点点
然后它的一些轮廓上它也会再更清晰
然后再更有立体感一点点
所以其实有时候在做两人份的时候
其实它在风味整体的强度上来说
它也会整体的变强
那粗细度有需要调整吗
其实我觉得可以不用
不用调整
我刚刚在做的手法是跟我平常在做的
只冲一人份的粗细度是完全一模一样的
其实我在设计的都会很简单
那为什么要去这样设计呢
一方面就像剛剛大家有看到的
就希望他的咖啡粉都是一直保持著
有在浸泡的狀態下
他不會忽然的
好像有些地方他沒有碰到水了
所以你會覺得說他就像是呼吸一下
有點上上下下
可是那個水又不會去淹過他的整個狀態
那其實像這樣子的咖啡
他的飽滿度跟他集中感
其實會是最好的
甜度也會是最佳的
如果你今天是喝的完一整
就是兩人份的話
其實因為你不用急著馬上喝完
因為其實好的咖啡他放到量也是很好喝的
你也可以試試看
今天我可能打算就是喝兩杯的量
然後喝喝同一杯
你可以試試看喝兩人份的沖泡
然後你可以從熱的喝到冷的
慢慢喝也沒有關係
然後其實你可以感受到
你跟平常沖一人份的狀況下
他其實還是會有差異的
可是我覺得這個差異不會讓你覺得說
完全換的不一樣的咖啡
而是原本的這個咖啡的立體度
他怎么样变得更高
他再冷一点
他的葡萄的掉性就跑出来了
他的转变性会更丰富一点点
对
好
有帮出吗
有
有什么问题要问我吗
蛤
问你
哈哈哈
对啊
还是一样再给大家
简单的一个小
也不是说
这是小知识
就是我个人的习惯
我觉得
你的手法如果越多啊
或者是越多变
其实人本身就是一个变因
可是如果你的變因一直不穩定
那咖啡它也很難穩定
所以你應該是讓它很多東西
它可以很簡化、好記、好操作
那剩下的你就讓咖啡自己去表現
它的好跟不好
那就好了
所以其實很多人他們在這邊會常問我的問題就是
每一支咖啡的沖煮方式都一樣嗎?
那我的回答是都一樣
對都一樣
好
那就
有什麼問題嗎?
沒有了
也歡迎各個廠商
如果有想玩具跟我們玩的話
我們可以幫你拍喔
對 我們可以拍喔
就是如果你有一些設備啊
我們幫你去做特試的
就歡迎你來找我們
我們現在就是
不一定要設備啦
不一定要那些什麼
都可以啦
可以做創條我們都可以來玩
對對對
我們現在很好講話
現在超好講話的
對 歡迎乾爹乾媽找我們
好
好 那就這樣囉
OK 拜拜